clay Higgins represents the state of
Louisiana Congressman thanks so much for
coming on
I mean did you I'm just wondering what
was going through your mind you asked
the basic question
decide are you gonna function without
petrochemicals did you expect her to
give you some answer
well I knew that her positions were
insane I mean Miss Salter is a radical
climate attorney some likely a friend of
aocs this was in the midst of of uh a
week where we had to endure Committee
hearing after Committee hearing where
the Democrats were smashing the American
Energy industry and promoting the
absurdities of the furthest reaches of
the green New Deal and their their star
witness after two days of of hearings on
the the second panel and the second day
was was this lady uh Miss Salter so I I
had possession of her written testimony
I'd read it I was prepared and I I knew
how crazy it read but then when she
delivered it in her opening statement
she was she was quite vitriolic she was
practically spitting at us and her anger
was just unbelievable so I knew when I
had the chance to I was gonna I was
going to shut her down with her own
crazy
boy you did such a good job thank you
for doing that Congressman Higgins
Louisiana appreciate it subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight